हुआ था नमस्कार जर्मन सीखिए हिंदी में कैन
एक्सपेक्ट में आपका स्वागत है आज हम सीखने
वाले हैं जर्मन केस part-3 लें और उसमें
हम सबसे इंपोर्टेंट चीज सीखने वाले हैं वह
है प्रेपोजिशन प्रपोजिशंस प्रीपोजिशंस
मतलब क्या कि जो हिंदी में हम बोलते हैं
केंद्र के निकट किरदार के साथ किरदार के
सिवा यह जो सारे हैं वह प्रपोजिशंस है और
किसी भी भाषा में वह बहुत इंपोर्टेंट होते
हैं इन फैक्ट जो सर्वनाम और जो क्रियाएं
होती है उ़डने इंपोर्टेंट होते हैं तो फिर
आप पूछोगे हमें इतने लेट क्यों सीख रहे
हैं 12 13 एपिसोड के बाद क्यों सीख रहे
हैं तो उसका भी एक रीजन है मित्रों
है कि
कि यह सिर्फ पोजीशन है जर्मन में उनके खुद
के कैसे सोते हैं और मुझे आपको ऐसे नहीं
था कि अभी के लिए आप यह समझ लो बाद में हम
यह समझते हैं मुझे आपको वह करेक्ट माइक
कंस्ट्रक्शन सिखाना था इसीलिए हम
प्रपोजिशंस अभी सी करें तो अभी नेक्स्ट 15
मिनट में हम इंपोर्टेंट 20 से 22 जर्मन
प्रपोजिशन सीखने वाले हैं और उनके फैंस भी
क्या है यह भी सीखें
है तो चलिए शुरू करते है सबसे पहले थोड़ा
सा रिवीजन करते हैं हमने देखा कि जर्मन
में हर निर्जीव वस्तु का भी जेंडर होता है
और उसके हिसाब से हमने दर्द की दास्तां
टेबल देखा आई लाइनर का भी टेबल देखा और
उससे माइन माइन अभी करना
है उसमें चीज देखी थी दोस्तों हमने कि विद
विच मतलब मिनट यह डाट यह ऊपर पोजीशन बोलते
हैं और मिलता है तो डी स्प्लैश वॉटर लगाते
थे यार सबको एक बार फिर से देखते हैं और
यह माय फादर में हमेशा रखूंगा तो सॉफ्ट कि
आप कोई कांस्टेंट रहेंगे तो पहले क्या
होगा हम देखते हैं आइए प्ले विद माय फादर
आईपीएल विथ माय फादर इसमें
को फिर से क्या करेंगे हमने को याद अगर
आपको तो माइक वंडरलैंड करेंगे और से
रिप्लेस करेंगे और विथ है इसलिए ट्यूब
फादर है कि मेल आई एम इसलिए होगा स्पीड
लिमिट माइ नेम फाइटर प्लेयर सबको स्पीड
लिमिट - फाइटर अगर यह क्लियर है तो बाकी
का एकदम सिंपल है जैसे कि मिनट एक ट्यूटर
पोजीशन तक वे संयम और थोड़े डिफरेंट
पोजीशन देखते हैं कौन है दिखाओ पहला नाक
नाक मतलब आफ्टर-आफ्टर आइटम आफ्टर माय फाइल
ओके खैरूल मतलब दो वृद्ध मोस्ट इंपॉर्टेंट
आई एम गो टू माय फादर है
और फिर उस हाउसेस आफ वॉटर आउट फिर है
बाय-बाय मतलब एक्स्ट्रा युवक टैप्सी एडिट
ओके ख्याल जॉइंट मतलब सींस आई एम लिविंग
इन यूनिक सिम्स टू व्हीलर लाइसेंस फॉर्म
फॉर मतलब ऑफ यह फ्रॉम और यह फ्रॉम तो यह
जो सारे है यह भी डाट यह डाट यह मतलब या
21 सितंबर लेते हैं तो आपके जो क्लियर हो
जाएगा सिंपल माय फादर ही रखेंगे हम
है तो पहले आई एम गो टू माय फादर आईएस को
टू माय फादर फिर से हम क्या करेंगे इस
माइक वंडरलैंड करेंगे और से रिप्लेस करें
कि अभी टू है तो मतलब जो है जो है तो क्या
है डांटते हुए और फादर क्या है मेल टू मेल
आईडी नेम माइ नेम इज देवरू माइ नेम फाइटर
सिंपल साइड सिमिलरली आईएफ कम आफ्टर माय
फादर कम आफ्टर माय फादर रिसेंटली इन चीजों
का माइक को अश्लील प्ले करो आफ्टर इज नॉट
हैव टाइम में आई नेम माय नेम इस कमल नायक
- मास्टर सिंपल इंपोर्टेंट है आपको तो
मिट्ठू नाथ जो है वह का अर्थ पता है तो
सिर्फ इतना याद रखना है जैसे यह पोजीशन
क्लियर है
जो अभी थोड़े प्रपोजिशन ऐसे हैं जो आपको
ट्यूब है जो आपको एक्टिविटी है मतलब कि हम
देखते हैं पहले वह प्रपोजिशन कौन है वह
देखते हैं हम फिर मतलब फॉर मोर
और फिर मतलब फॉर पूर्ण मतलब विदाउट ओवन
मतलब कि दबी अदरक को मिट मतलब कि डाइटिंग
तक होना विदाउट आप सिटी में क्यों है
लैंग्वेज ओके ब्रिज मतलब तेल 20 मतलब तेल
दुरुस्त मतलब रुद्राक्ष मतलब शुरू लेकिन
मतलब मतलब मतलब मतलब यह जो पोजीशन है वह
है दोस्तों और वह हम देखते हैं
है तो यह क्यों रोने कैसे करेगा निर्वहन
दो एग्जांपल देखते हैं तो आपको एकदम हिंदी
नहीं पता चल जाएगा तो सबसे पहले माय फादर
furniture1 है आइए कुक फॉर माय फादर लाइक
और माय फादर फिर क्या होगा माइक को अब या
फिर अ गुज़रते हुए कुलसचिव मेल आई एम -
इश्क पोखर फिर - सिंपल ही कम विदाउट ऊ
को फिर से किसको अंडरलाइन होगा माइक को और
किया विदाउट क्या है और न ओनर है आपको 600
इसीलिए होगा कुछ टू मेल फाइनेंस महीने
इसको मा ओन माइंड एंड फास्टर थन सिंपलेस्ट
फिर से आपको क्या याद रखना
को जड़ से मिटा तो इसलिए करते थे वैसे अगर
यह पोजीशन है तो ऐड करना है क्लियर सबको
अब हम थर्ड टाइम को प्रपोजिशन सकते हैं जो
बहुत आसान है मतलब प्रपोजल खुद बहुत आसान
है और यह बहुत ही यूज करते हैं तो यह मेरे
साथ सी को अभिनय को इंग्लिश में अगर आप
सिर पर हाथ रखते हो सिर पर हाथ रखते हुए
मेज पर पुस्तक रखते हो तो भी उसको और ही
बोलते हैं और अगर आप घड़ी यह तस्वीर अगर
दीवार पर लगाते हो तो उससे भी ऑन बोलते
हैं राइट जर्मन में ऐसे नहीं है दोनों अलग
है तो वह कहते हैं आपको टेबल में तो इसका
मीनिंग दिखेगा पर जहां पर मेरे पास ध्यान
रखो आपको इजी डैंड्रफ ऐसे ही याद रखोगे ना
तो आपको आसानी से याद रहेगा लेकिन मेरे
साथ
के अंदर देखो मेरा हाथ चेहरे के ऐसे ऊपर
है आने
कि अब मतलब वर्टिकल ऊपर आओ ट्यूब स ऊपर
मतलब वो अब वो एंटर एंटर मतलब नीचे नीचे
और आगे E4 आगे इंटर पीछे इंटर पीछे ने
बलधीर विशेषण दोनों के बीच में जो दोनों
हाथों के बीच फिर से आप भी आओ
ए लुक अट र ओन ट
थे फोर हुए इंटरनेट इन थिस सिचुएशन और
आखिरी मिलता है कि इन मतलब इन इंग्लिश का
इन जर्मन का इन अब हम प्रपोजिशंस दीजिए ना
बहुत बार यूज करते हैं गैदर प्रॉब्लम दैट
मैं क्या है थोड़ा सा जो लोग यहां पर
कंफ्यूज होते हैं वह है कि यह चेंजिंग
प्रपोजिशंस को वेक्टर पोजीशन बोलते हैं अब
चेंजेस प्रपोज मतलब क्या यह कभी आपको साठी
होते हैं कभी डाक के होते हैं थोड़ा
मुश्किल लगाना पर सिंपल है उसकी मैं आपको
ट्रिक एक देता हूं तो कैसे या रखना है अगर
आप उसी जगह पर है मतलब जो आपका सेंटेंस हो
रहा है तो आप उसी जगह पर हूं अगर क्वेश्चन
है वह व तो आप ढु और अगर आपकी जगह चेंज हो
रही है क्वेश्चन है वह इक तो अब आपको
ट्यूब यह थोड़ा वर्ष में समझना मुश्किल है
इसलिए मैंने एग्जांपल कहते हैं दो वह आप
अगर समझ लो तो मैं तो
* को जाते हो तब भी यह एकदम पर लेकर
रिवर्स इंजीनियरिंग करता था वह मैं आपको
बताता हूं जर्मन में जो रेस्तरों या
रेस्टोरेंट इसको बोलते हैं वह आता है
न्यूट्रल न्यूट्रल ओके तो हम पहले रूल
देखते हैं आई टिंडर रेस्टोरेंट आईद
रेस्टोरेंट तो किसको बाध अपॉइंटमेंट हो
गया अभी इन डिफरेंट नहीं करेगा इंडिया
साइड नहीं करेगा डिसाइड करेगा उससे पहले
आप खा रहे एक जगह पर बैठ कर खा रहे हैं
है तो जगह चेंज है नहीं तो हम लोग की
शिकायत ट्यूम तो ट्यून न्यूट्रल क्या होगा
डैम इसी लिए इस ऐसा इन डैम रेस्टोरेंट ओके
वैसे ही आईएस गोइंग रेस्टोरेंट में गोविंद
शोल्डर लेंथ करो अगेन इन नहीं करेगा तो अब
जा रहे हैं तो उस टाइम क्या होगा आपको
इसीलिए आपको इसके दांत रेस्टोरेंट
रेस्टोरेंट क्योंकि मैं एक जगह पर था इस
गेरोनिमो क्योंकि मैं यह याद रखिए और करते
जैसे मैंने बोला आज पहले दिन इस मिक्सचर
को इतना जरूर
हु इज द टाइम आपको आता जाएगा इंपोर्टेंट
है कि आप यह आर्म आफ यह समझ लो और दूसरी
चीज है कि यह जो सारे दर्द होता है या आई
लाइनर किसको लगता है नॉर्मल मंत्र को कौन
उसको हम प्रॉपर नाउन है तो आपने बोलते आए
प्ले विद जब केदार नहीं बोलते रहेगी वैसे
ही आई स्टे नियर किरदार आईंस्टीन ईयर
किरदार या फिर आई स्टैंड नियर किरदार होगा
का यह इश्क टैगोर ने बन किरदार देर उसका
डाकियों गलत सोचने की जरूरत ही नहीं है जब
आप केदार ओवी यह डायरेक्ट प्रॉपर नुस्खे
यह टेंशन है कि नहीं तो इंपोर्टेंट क्या
है पहले यह आर्म आफ वगैरह समझ लो वैक्सीन
प्रपोज बेसिकली यह दो सेंटेंस याद रखो
जैसे-जैसे टाइम जैसे आपका यह जर्मन अच्छा
होता जाएगा अपने आप आपको वेबसाइट पर कृष्ण
ने कंस समझ में आएंगी
कि संजय दत्त को अभी हमने 3 प्रपोजिशंस के
टाइम देखिए
डूओ प्रपोजिशंस आपको साइकिल प्रेड पोजीशन
पर मैक्सिमम लिए सबसे पहले क्या करो पहले
यह 2022 प्रपोजिशन जब वह समझ लो एक किताब
में लिख लो उनकी प्रेक्टिस करो और फिर भी
केसेस क्या है उनके साथ यूज करो टू बी
होने से सब्सक्राइब और मैंने कौन से हैं
मिनट ज़ुलु नाक पद्धतियों में और फिर
उन्हें अपडेट यह आप सबसे ज्यादा यूज करने
वाले हो आवाज नवयुवक यौवन के पर वह जनरल
में मेनी टाइम बैक कंप्लीट प्रॉब्लम पिंपल
अभी कि सिस्टम प्रिंट करने से पहले मैंने
आपको पहले पार्ट में बताया था इनडायरेक्ट
ऑब्जेक्ट का intersect ऑब्जेक्ट का विडियो
केसे होता है मैं आपको बताऊंगा और इसके
लिए यह सेंटेंस आप याद रखना यह सेंटेंस
अगर आपको समझ लिया तो आपको किस इसका तारा
आ गया शांति सेंटेंस है गौर
ए माय फादर गिव्स माय सन माय बॉईल माय
फादर गिव्स माय सन माय बॉईल फादर गिव्स
माय सन मैं बॉईल कर्ता कौन है माय फादर है
करेक्ट तो होंगे नॉमिनेटिव कर्म कौन है
मैं बॉईल देखकर तो व होंगे अ को सेटिंग और
माय सन माय संख्या है इनडायरेक्ट ऑब्जेक्ट
तेरे किसको तो वह होगा डायरेक्टिव डाट याद
है सबको तो वैसे ही कैसे कैसे करेंगे हम
माय फादर के लिए क्या होगा नॉमिनेटिव मेल
आई एम इसीलिए माइंड बॉडी के लिए कुलसचिव
मेल आईने इसलिए माइंथ और संघ के लिए
कि डाइजेस्टिव मेल इसीलिए हो का या आई न
इसीलिए माइ नेम तो सेंटेंस क्या होगा देखो
माइंड आफ्टर गिफ्ट माइंथ गिफ्ट क्यों छोड़
दो हम थोड़े वीरवर सीखेंगे तब सीखेंगे
आपके सबसे इंपोर्टेंट सेंटेंस याद रखना है
यह आ गया तो आपको कैसे सा गए
थे माइंड आफ्टर गिफ्ट माइ नेम जोन माइन इन
थिस व्होल शांति चाहिए तो एक बार डिवाइड
करके देखिए यह आपको समझ में आया तो किससे
समझ में आए तो अभी देखो हमने क्या
इनडायरेक्ट ऑब्जेक्ट कि कैसे यूज करना
सीखा है तो लास्ट 3 एपिसोड में मैं के
हमने कैसे इसके सारे जो बेसिक है वह सारे
क्लियर की है
कि मेरी आपसे फिर एक बार रिक्वेस्ट है कि
यह तीनों पॉइंट्स शर्मिला कहती हैं कि
लगभग 1 घंटे का या शांति से देख लो आपके
से पूरी तरह से क्लियर हो जाएंगे कोई भी
आपको अगर डाउट है तो कमेंट बॉक्स में
पूछिए मैं उनके आंसर देने का प्रयत्न
करूंगा एक तक हरी मिशन लेता है सबसे पहले
अपने क्या ने कहा कि हिंदी की तरह जर्मनी
में भी अलग-अलग जेंडर है यह व निर्जीव
वस्तुओं को भी उसके बाद हमने दर किंड आफ
का टेबल देखना सिखा फिर हमने नाइन का टेबल
देखना सीखा उसका यूज करके मेरा मेरी माइंड
साइंस इन करना सीखा फिर आज हमने देखा कि
कुछ प्रपोजिशंस हैं जो खुदा पूजा डेमो
सकते हैं और उसके बाद हमने इनडायरेक्ट
ऑब्जेक्ट का बेटा क्यों करना सीखा एकदम
सॉलिड अगर आप करता हो सब्जेक्ट तो
नॉमिनेटिव हो अगर आप कर्म हो ऑब्जेक्ट हो
तो आप उसे ट्यूब या फिर अगर आप यह कॉर्नर
के साथ ऑब्जेक्टिव हो और अगर आप
इनडायरेक्ट ऑब्जेक्ट हो
हैं या फिर आप मेड फ्रॉम जून आपके साथ हो
तो आप डायटिंग हो यह एक्ट्रेस मेल फीमेल
रिमिक्स इस आपके किस हो गए मुझे आशा है कि
आप सबको यह कि समझ में आई होगी हम मिलते
हैं नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में धन्यवाद ल